[Music]
I wrote in about how to be more
respectful or be a better husband be
nicer to my wife found where there's
been a few occasions where I've
corrected her in front of people she
probably trivial this type of criticism
is almost always about you not
[Music]
her what up what up this is John with
the Dr John Del
show so grateful that you've joined us
you're spending some time with us today
talking about your mental and emotional
health your physical health your
marriage your relationships kids
whatever you got going on in your life
shows about real people trying to figure
out what's the next right step so much
nonsense out there there's so much chaos
out there there's so much bad news out
there and people are either just stuck
or they are hitting the gas and spinning
their tires in the mud and just making
can the hold deeper and deeper and
deeper and on this show we just say stop
let's turn the lights on let's turn the
music off let's stop the dance and let's
figure out what can we do next to make
this situation a little bit better let's
head towards hope if you want to be on
the show give me a buzz 1844 693 3291 or
go to johal.com
askk and it's holiday season go get the
questions for humans cards they may be
sold out by the time this is out at John
don.com Thanksgiving Christmas um
grandparents and kids grandparents and
kids and of course the couples decks for
those of you who are like I don't know
if I want to be married to you in 2024
or dating anymore we got you we got you
all right let's go out to West Palm
Beach Florida and talk to Buck what's up
Buck good morning good morning what's up
Dr John how you doing we're we're
getting it done man how about you
partying in my living room right now
which is not true but
okay how can I help man big fan I want
you to know this is like talking to
family by the way uh we're huge huge
fans of of you guys of your whole team I
appreciate you letting me be a part of
your fam dude that's awesome
absolutely um I wrote in about how to be
more respectful or be a better husband
be nicer to my wife um and that's I
guess that's a big big thing and we'll
drill down into it yeah it uh usually
takes a lot for a man to pick up the
phone and make that call so what's been
going
on uh you know like most recently it's
just been kind of like
nitpicky stuff like cooking or um you
know I've I've found where there's been
a few occasions where I've corrected her
in front of people on you know probably
trivial stuff or details about stories
or stuff like that and you know in my
mind I'm like you know what there's a
little Jiminy Cricket that should be in
there that should filter the stuff
before I say it out loud and I think
maybe he's broken or on
vacation wow yeah
so here's my hot
take this type of criticism and really
most all
criticism is almost always about you not
her it's this idea that you're chasing a
feeling of what you will feel like when
everything in your world is
perfect or specific to her you're
chasing a feeling of what you're going
to feel like when she does everything
right when she cooks the meal exactly
right and you sit down and eat it and
she gets the details of the story just
right and her body looks just right
these little nitpicky the the little
nitpicky things or the big things right
criticism is is almost never about the
other person it's about you and it
almost always stems from the fact that
you don't like your
life dang okay tell me tell me I'm wrong
I see that no no no I I can see that I
can definitely see that why don't you
like your
life uh
gosh I think it's been and and I'll just
say this we you know she and I have both
been in recovery from Al for the last
year
is nine months actually uh for me and so
so it's not fun
anymore you're I mean the the smoke is
cleared you're in the grind out phase
right we are we are we are absolutely
and um and that you know again that was
like a thing we've been together for
five years and you know and that was a
part of our entire you know existence
together up to this point and so it's
like now we're figuring out like how
we're how we work moving forward and so
there's you know that's a lot there's a
lot of stuff to deal with right there's
a lot of things maybe that I'm for sure
that I haven't dealt with in my life
throughout my life the same goes for her
so then I think but hold on she she's
not on the phone so let's just deal with
you and you're probably pretty good at
feeling like I need to work on a
thing and then you bring everybody in on
that because it's all of our
fault
fair fair yeah I want to just deal with
you
okay what is it about you that you don't
think you're enough when you're sitting
down at the table because let me let me
give like a let me give a like a 30,000
foot View and what I'm going to say is
embarrassing okay just a shameful thing
in my life I I am an embarrassment to
Texas males everywhere the entire
stereotype when it comes to grilling I'm
terrible at it I forget I burn it I put
like this beautiful raw piece of meat in
front of my f I'm embarrassing at it and
so cooking is about
eating and I'm terrible at it when my
wife's gone my son and I eat something
that he has named Hank and Dad mush
that's everything in in the in the
fridge that's left my wife didn't
criticize me and just sit there and poke
and poke and poke because for her
cooking is about
eating she went and became the best
griller I know I have a hard time buying
a steak at a restaurant anymore because
she's so good at cooking it and so
instead of telling me how much I sucked
and what a loser I was she wasn't
chasing a feeling because she likes her
life what she wanted was to eat well and
so as a partner she took that part of
our relationship
on and so that's something as simple as
cooking or as simple as getting a story
right you though don't like
you and I'm wondering if nine months
into being sober you're just tired of
standing on the street corner without
any clothes
on
gosh that could I mean that could
absolutely be
true and and and again there's you know
still like CU we're in a step program
I'm not I haven't really really you know
gotten into the weave
into me it's been you know it's been on
the surface and it's been okay you know
we're flying This Plane sober for you
know doing it but you're nine months in
do me a favor talk directly into the
phone for me um sorry you you've been
doing this for n9ine months now and I'm
not talking about going spelunking back
to your childhood and all that I'm
asking about the little
things do you treat your body with
dignity and respect do you work out do
you exercise you go for walks do you
like only eat garbage on purpose not
just as a way of
life yesterday was Halloween and I kind
of went for it I kind of went for it but
I I planned for it right do you have any
sort of spiritual practice do you have a
group of buddies outside of AA that you
just sit around and hang out with and
you know you have value to them just
because you show up not because you have
some special
skill I do I have a group of uh men that
I you know like Core group of men that
are close friends that we you know we
speak often and we speak about these
things
too actually had a call this morning uh
with with one of
them after after Halloween often this
idea that I don't like like my life or I
don't like the role I'm playing in my
own story I don't like how I feel
exposed like
this um Can often be distilled down to I
don't trust me
yet or I don't tell myself the truth and
that can be all the way out to addiction
that can be to pornography but that can
also be things like I'm going to go work
out tomorrow and then you don't I'm
going to start eating right tomorrow and
then you don't I'm going to be really
nice to my wife I'm going to keep my
mouth shut tonight cuz I'm always poking
at her and then you don't and so you get
the criticism of your wife but beneath
that you know that you can't even trust
you and that usually is what sends
people on their tail spin either that or
they're trying to protect themselves
from
something I had a um it hasn't come out
yet um but I I recently
had the comedian John Christ on the show
interviewed him and um it was a pretty
extraordinary conversation he was way
more open vulnerable than I expected and
um he mentioned something that I've only
heard people in impatient recovery say
and it's very true and he was talking
about somebody that he was in recovery
with um who had been just tragically
sexually
abused and he said that she was very
clear alcohol saved her
life and here she was in rehab trying to
come up with plan C because plan a was
torture Plan B was I can save my life
with this thing and now this thing is
killing me so I'll ask you what was
alcohol protecting you
from I think you were drinking because
it worked what what was it working to
help you
with I think it was keeping you know the
I get again like the real conversations
between she and I those at Bay right and
and I I mean if if I'm honest I almost
feel like I'm protecting myself from my
wife I don't know if that sounds strange
or not not at all because she can hurt
you real bad if you go all in
right yeah you been burned
before well I've been I was divorced but
it was my it was my choice you know yeah
but but but you had a picture of what
your life was going to look like and
that picture
collapsed right
right yeah
and you know her go-to has been to bail
you know when things get tough or when
things get seedy or you know our
conversation she's like well you know we
should probably separate I'm like well I
disagree you know I'm like that's not
the that wasn't the plan you know and so
my guess is y'all have some sort of
dance where you are terrified of
somebody leaving you so you leave first
or you duct tape over those feelings and
you squash them down with alcohol with
xanax with whatever you need to
do and
she is tortured yet needs to learn to
head into the storm which for her is
I've got to lean towards this disc this
discomfort this uncomfortable
conversation I can't bail every time
because she leans back and your alarm
sound and that makes you poke and that
makes her alarm sound which makes her
Retreat more and then you get louder and
then the whole dance goes and goes and
goes until one of you has the courage to
I'm not dancing
anymore right and I end up on the phone
with you right so here here's here's
plan number
one just like you did in the first
couple of months in
AA I want you to take your wife
somewhere out to eat get out of the
environment in your home and I want you
to look her dead in the eye probably
write this down so you can read it and I
want you to tell her I have been
treating you like I'm better than
you and I criticize and I poke and I
blame because I'm
scared and I'm sorry and that ends right
now then I want you to look her in the
eye and say I may stop myself halfway
through a sentence at a
party I might get up and walk away for
30 seconds or for 30 minutes I will come
back but I refuse to be disrespectful to
you I'm not going to criticize you
anymore because criticism is about me
not
you we both know you're not a great cook
awesome but I want to eat so I'm going
to learn how to cook or we're just going
to have a season to takeout till we
figure this
out
right right now accountability is
different than criticism accountability
is a
partnership accountability is when I
call my friend Lane Norton and I say hey
I'm going to try to lose this much
weight I'm going to text you every week
and he goes I got you or my friend
Jordan SC hey I'm going to I'm going to
send you pictures of the scale once
every few weeks and if you don't get one
holler at me that's accountability
that's not
criticism right that's somebody agreeing
to walk alongside me as I get better in
your wife's case hey I'm GNA really make
an effort to learn how to cook I want
you to be honest with me every meal and
you go are you are you super sure right
like I'll I'll walk alongside you that's
different than just bombing and
criticizing and criticizing and
bombing and that's step one coming to
her and saying this ends step two is
making a plan to get up stop the cycle
when you start criticizing when you
start poking when you start throwing
little grenades not big ones little
Annoying ones and the third one is what
do you need to do on a daily basis is to
regain trust with buck and to start
feeling alive in your own home again
spoiler alert you can only feel alive
gosh I hate saying this because it's it
I wish there was another way you can
only feel alive through vulnerability
period you have to be willing to say ah
here's what I
need ah here's what I want from
you can you help me meet this need it
might be sexual it might be friendship
wise it might be go for a walk it might
be I want to lose some weight it might
be any number I want to get another job
any number of things but you got to be
willing to put it out
there and she might say oh thank God yes
I'm in or she might go I ain't doing
that and now I got to live with that
tension and that reality but you're
avoiding it avoidance avoidance
avoidance
avoidance you've done some really
amazing work being 9 months over I'm
super proud of you man that is really
hard especially doing it with somebody
else that you live with y'all are
radically changing the dynamic of your
home and that's hard it's
impressive both of you need to take the
next step which
is what do you need from me so that you
can be whole and help me with what I
need and so then I can help you and
we're going to walk alongside each other
building a new marriage that way
you got this my friend I'm going to send
you two copies of building a non-anxious
life I want you and your wife to read
that book together give you a road map
not for addiction you keep going to your
meetings absolutely don't stop going to
your meetings it's going to give you a
road map to begin to build a house where
youall trust yourselves you trust each
other and you
Build A Home of Peace and for your body
dude peace feels scary right
now but you keep practicing and you keep
practicing
proud of you
man start respecting your wife stop
criticizing you live a life worth living
we'll be right
back hey delone here and it's pumpkin
spice latte season just kidding that's
disgusting but it is fall it's a little
cooler the sun's going down earlier and
God help us daylight savings time is
ending or starting or whatever the time
is the time is changing again again and
it can be exhausting to adjust to
everything all the time so make sure
you're moving your body every day
getting sunlight in the morning and in
the evening and getting 7 to n hours of
sleep each night I can't stress enough
how important this is sleep is the
Cornerstone to physical and mental and
emotional health and for me great sleep
starts with an amazing mattress that's
why I love dreamcloud and why my family
sleeps on dreamcloud and right now
dreamcloud is running an awesome offer
40% off all mattresses plus an
additional $50 in savings exclusively
for our listeners go to dreamcloud
sleep.com and enter promo code John
deloney that's dreamcloud sleep.com with
code John delone for 40% off all
mattresses and an extra $50 in
savings all right let's go out to
Birmingham a Alabama talk to The Sun
Will Come Out Tomorrow to talk to Annie
what's up Annie hi John how are you so
good how are you I'm doing well thank
you for asking awesome what's
up well my question for you is how can I
talk with my husband about the way that
he communicates with our
children tell me
more he can be um very demeaning at
times and
belittling um especially to my daughter
she uh will be 10 later this month and I
have noticed a change in her
behavior um recently and she's come to
me in confidence and told me that you
know it really hurts her feelings the
way that that he speaks with her um give
me an
example
so um say
she's um trying to make herself a
sandwich
and she makes a mess so instead of uh
telling her okay it's time to clean up
the mess you know don't forget to put
your dishes in the in the dishwasher he
just loses it I can't believe you made
this mess in the kitchen you know why
does it take you so long to clean up
afterward those kinds of
things and he talks to you this way too
otherwise you wouldn't be calling me
he does
yeah when's enough
enough put your kids aside for a second
when's enough enough for
you I'm not
sure here's the deal he is dramatically
unhappy happy with his
life he doesn't like him he doesn't like
how he feels he thought everything in
his life was going to feel
different look
different and if your 10-year-old
daughter made a
sandwich and unlike any 10-year-old on
planet Earth she immediately cleaned up
every
crumb he would criticize how loud she
chews he would criticize the way she
walked to the table she would criticize
why did you use two pieces of hand ham
instead of just one piece of ham you
know how expensive ham
is because his criticism and grenade
throwing is not about y'all it's about
him and he's not on the
phone you
are what has it been like in the past
when you've said hey stop talking to me
like that or have
you usually he automatically becomes the
victim
and he says things like oh well I guess
I'm just trash or I guess I'm just not
good enough you know for
you man that's a gaslighting
manipulative young man right
there so I'll ask you again how
long how long have y'all been married 18
years how long's you been doing
this
I would say the
first
eight to 10 years were really
good um and things kind of changed after
we had our daughter the focus shifted
from just he and I to
her you know what that's called it's
called adulthood and
maturity you know you know what I mean
like it's not
like that's everybody life when you have
kids you have kid number one your
marriage changes it gets
weird your money's different your sex
life is different your communication is
different you got to rebuild something
new and if you don't you go to shame or
embarrassment or I don't like my life
and then you either withdraw from
humanity and just drink beer and watch
Netflix for the rest of your life or you
just start attacking people in your
life and making your discomfort in your
dislike for who you have become in your
own life you make that everybody else's
fault well how do I break that cycle for
my children I don't I don't want them to
continue to
live
in feeling like they're not good enough
I know how that feels but I don't want
them to continue into
that
you're probably going to have to have
some conversations and take some actions
you that scare you to
death and probably the conversation
starts
with I'm going to be real direct with
you and if you start saying things like
well I guess I'm just the worst and I'm
just trash then you are opting out of
this conversation I need you to stay
present with me don't whine don't
immediately make yourself the drama
victim I want to solve this thing for
our marriage and for our
kids and if he cannot hear that then you
tell
him we're going to have to talk about
next steps until you go get some
professional help because you're unable
to have an adult conversation with your
wife but you have to be ready for that
conversation cuz you don't like
discomfort and when he starts his woe as
me that that ws havoc on your body
doesn't
it it does yeah who else did that to you
in your
life my mom
yeah my parents were divorced when I was
six and she left and so my dad that
raised
me was it your job to make sure mama was
okay it felt that way
yeah was it also your job to put a
smiley face on cuz Dad was sad a
lot we had to make things okay even if
they weren't that's that's how it felt
that's not how it felt that's how it was
so I'll just tell you and six-year-old
anny I'm sorry that you were responsible
for that because that wasn't your
job whether they stayed married or got
divorced it was your parents' job to
take care of their emotions and their
happiness and their grief and their
heartbreak that was never your
job and the same way your 10-year-old
daughter feels like she has to walk on
eggshells with her dad and that her
actions are being scrutinized under a
microscope and she has to perform for
him that's not her job
either and you know this this is why you
called but I'm going to say it out loud
anyway your kids are desperate for an
adult in their life who loves them to
step in between this
madness and it may be the the what I the
the like the conversation prompt I gave
you a minute ago that may be too much
it may be a matter of you sitting down
with your husband saying you have done
this to me for 10 years and I'm watching
you do this to your kids this ends now
and you can go down the woe as me I'm
just trash and that's stupid and that's
a cowardly way to bow out of a hard
conversation you can do that and if you
walk away from this table then you're
choosing to walk away from this house
for 30 days while we figure out what's
next or you can stay engaged and we can
figure this thing out
I think at this point you are closer to
the edge of this marriage than you want
to say out loud is that
true I felt that way for a while yeah do
you have somebody
else no okay no I love my husband
implicitly I know but you also are
coming around to understand that you
don't deserve this and your kids don't
deserve
this and your husband either a lacks the
tools every time he reaches in his
toolkit it's empty and so he just goes
to dragging the rest of y'all
down and counseling they call it there
there's the one up position which is the
screaming and yelling and the how dare
you and there's the one down position
which is the I guess that I'm just the
worst ever I guess we'll just go have
that food I just won't eat that's fine
that's a power play
too and like you mentioned usually it's
moms who do that but it happens with
husbands too especially
increasingly
but you have to have a confrontation is
what I'm telling you are you safe to do
that will he hit you no he's never been
abusive not physically okay will he
scream and cuss and yell at
you he may
okay I think you preface the
conversation with we're going to have a
hard conversation and if you scream and
yell you're out I want you to
go can you have an adult conversation
with your adult wife
role playay that with me if you were to
say that to him what was his what would
his response be you've been with him 20
years you know what he'll
say what do you mean we need to have a
conversation about what I thought
everything was fine it's not fine and I
need you to sit down and listen very
carefully to what I'm about to tell you
and I don't want you to start defending
S I want you to finally listen to the
words I'm going to say can you do
that what would he
say he's such a wild card I don't know
okay I don't sometimes it would be okay
I listen and sometimes it would be well
you know I've been at work all day and I
don't know what this nonsense is about
cool I've been working
too if right now is not a good time you
tell me when it is but it needs to be
within 24
hours and if he gets up and won't have
the conversation you can be very clear
then we're going to have this with a
therapist or we're going to have this
with an attorney you get to
pick and here's what we're
doing if you told me you were unsafe or
that you were vulnerable that he was had
a chance to hurt you I would not
recommend this but here's what we're
doing we're shaking the tree
here he needs to know that his little
pity party wo is me I'm just the that is
that that that game is
over you're not
going to talk to my kids you're not
going to make my children fearful in
their own home period you've been doing
it to me for 10 years it ends
now
and my hope is your resolve will be so
clear that he'll stand up a little
straighter and listen to
you or when he starts his woe is me
stuff you say nope we're stopping that
right now are you going to continue to
listen are you going to make yourself a
victim in this
conversation or well I'm guess I'm just
trash you're allowed to talk to yourself
that way I would never talk to somebody
that way that's a distraction let's get
back back
too and you may need Annie you may need
to go sit with a professional counselor
and practice this
conversation and you've gotten real
quiet am I scaring you is this whole
idea scaring you or are you feeling
empowered I'm feeling like I need to to
find that strength I don't know if I
possess it but I want to I think you
do I think you
do I also
understand and I've been there too where
I wanted somebody else in the room with
us I wanted a counselor there I wanted a
professional or a pastor I wanted
somebody in the room to make sure a I
was saying things the right way and be
making sure that the whole conversation
stayed on the track stayed on stayed on
the
rails when I find myself unable to feel
like I have the strength I always write
it down that way I can go through
multiple drafts and I can be very clear
about what I want to say I read it out
loud and I will sometimes have somebody
else with
me does that work for you I think that
could be the difference between being
able to do it and not okay I think
that's very fair I also am not a huge
fan of not a huge fan of the surprise at
attack I like adults to act like
adults right and so you and me are going
to a
meeting well I've been working all day
I'm tired I Ain going to some stupid
meeting your marriage is at risk I need
you to come to this meeting with me what
what do you mean my marriage is at risk
I thought everything's fine it's not
fine I need you to come to this meeting
I've arranged child care for our kids
it's at 6 o'clock I need you to be there
and we're not negotiating we're not
having multiple like rounds of this whoa
whoaa whoa I've said what I need to say
I'll say the rest of it at this
meeting can you do
that I think I can okay and if he wants
to call I'd love to talk to
him okay he probably won't but I'd love
to talk to him
too but I'll say this
again and I don't say this to pile on I
say this because because you're the
adult your daughter came to you and said
Mom help
me and she's watching and experiencing
your response in real
time and six-year-old
Annie is also asking you how long are we
going to do
this and I think it's time to set her
free
too
I think you have the strength in fact I
know you
do make a very clear plan and get
somebody else that's going to be in the
room with you and maybe it's a couple
that you all trust maybe it's another
man that you trust that's friends with
your husband it could be any any you
decide who that
[Music]
is but your kids deserve peace in their
own home and you do
too and quite frankly so does your
husband
call me back
anytime um I'm really interested to see
how this one plays out so holler back at
me after youall have this
meeting we'll be thinking about you
we'll be right
back hey good folks delone here with
some great news you get to choose
whatever you do good or bad moving
forward the choice is yours and when
you're intentional about making good
choices over time those become healthy
habits they almost become automatic like
choosing to slow down and make time for
a daily practice of prayer and
meditation one thing that has helped me
with my daily practice is hallow hallow
is the number one Prayer app in the
world and they're giving you three free
months to get started that's three
months for free to prioritize your
mental and spiritual health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music through guided prayers
meditation and more and by the way
hallow isn't just Catholic you can
tailor the content towards your faith
tradition or if you don't have a faith
tradition it's a great place to start
from scripture readings to prayers to
journaling Hall makes it easy to
practice mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember hallow is giving you 90
days free imagine the peaceful habits
you can establish in 90 days go to
hall.com dealone today to start your
free trial just follow the simple
prompts at at hall.com
dealone for 90 days
free all right welcome back so we are
wrapping up the six daily choices series
it's a series um if you if you're just
now catching up it's a series that walk
through the six daily choices to
building a non- anxious life and it's
bigger than that it's this new way of
doing life the way culture has told us
that everything's about you you're the
center of the universe if something
makes you uncomfortable they need to
change that needs to be fixed the rules
of of basic
um universal laws they don't really
count anymore if you're uncomfortable if
you're not if it's not real right in
this anxiety that's just pulsing through
all of us so we've gone through a series
and we sat down with an amazing film
crew and we filmed these six daily
choices and today is the final one it's
the one that I went back and forth on to
leave out of the book it's the one that
I felt most uncomfortable writing cuz I
knew I had to put it in there and I was
going to make everybody
uncomfortable and it's the one that I've
got the most feedback from
positively and in fact normally I would
kind of unpack it a little bit I'm not
going to do that this time here's what
I'm going to say because I want you to
listen to the the depth and the breadth
of this
conversation everything in our culture
everything has pointed us over the last
hundred years years and accelerating in
the last 20 years to this
idea that you can be
self-actualized that if you get all of
these things if you get all safety and
food and water and connection and all
these
things then you will one day be a
shining beacon on the
hill the universe will one day revolve
around you and what you feel and what
you
think and your truth
and what we're all finding out in real
time is that the self was never intended
to
hold the center can't hold you my friend
were never designed to hold up the
universe and so a Cornerstone of
building a non-anxious life of giving
your body peace is stepping back and
taking a
knee taking a need of something bigger
than you some call it a higher power
some call it
God some call it nature whatever you
want to call it but it's this idea that
I'm going to back
up just like our ancient civilizations
did they looked up to the sky and they
said dear God or Gods please rain or my
kids will
die and now we have a faucet in our
house or a couple of them we've gotten
real arrogant like we're running things
around
here and our body knows that's not
true so turn it up a little bit if you
have the ability to to find a private
space to listen to this this um final
daily Choice do that if you can have
have have an opportunity to watch it on
YouTube do that as
well this is the last of the six daily
choices to building a non-anxious life
it's choosing belief check it
out so this is the one that's going to
get me in trouble cuz it's easy to tell
somebody hey you got to be healthy hey
you got to deal with past hurts you got
to deal with your relationship
challenges and and loneliness but we've
entered a space in our culture where
it's not cool to say hey if you want to
live a non-anxious life if you want
peace you have to choose belief you have
to choose to believe in something big
bigger than
yourself this idea of I don't believe in
anything that's a modern privilege all
of human history until just a couple
hundred years ago people walked out of
their tent they walked out of their Hut
they walked out of their cave and they
looked to the sky and they said dear God
or dear Gods please reain or my kids
will die there's an innate sub mission
to a higher power something that
operates the cosmos and then we got real
smart we started solving some of these
issues that have plagued Humanity for
all of human history lack of food winter
how do we eat ah now I got a cell phone
I just push a button and food shows up
at my house clean water just turn that
nozzle and we started
deconstructing us the way we think about
things and feel about things and we
created this idea that the goal of human
existence is
self-actualization if you get safety and
you get security and you get food and
you get relationships the world will
then revolve around you and here we are
you and me we have everything and we're
spinning out of control because the self
was never designed to be actualized the
self was never designed to hold up the
burdens of the universe and now we
worship the thing that we think will
save us we worship our political party
we worship our physical health we
worship our money as the great David
Foster Wallace says we are beings
created to worship and Foster Wallace
was an atheist this wasn't a religious
statement this was a fact and what we're
all finding out you and me and all of us
in real
time that they don't hold they're not
going to save
us building a non-anxious
life is about surrender about taking a
knee and saying I can't hold up the
universe there's a higher power than me
in
action choosing belief comes in two
important parts letting go and anchoring
into the
source for all of human history Gods
decided what you wore what your roles
were who did what and why yes there was
oppression yes people got squashed but
the point was there was a unifying story
and in the last few years we've clipped
all the unifying stories we've
untethered oursel from the source and
when you let go and you're not anchored
in you become a balloon or a feather
lost in the Wind on the other side
if you anchor in and you don't let go
you become a source of political
division and tension trying to die on
every Hill it's a way of pretending that
you're not holding up the universe but
you're still trying to hold it with all
your might so you have to Anchor in you
have to believe in something bigger than
yourself and for my science friends it's
got to be bigger than the scientific
method we've worshiped that for the last
few hundred years and for my deeply
religious passionately religious friends
it has to be deeper than your sets of
rules we're talking about the source
we're talking about God we're talking
about the love that moves through the
universe and holds all things together
and as a science nerd I don't want that
to be the case as somebody who spent my
whole life trying to use my intellect to
solve why I had such a gaping hole
inside of me I don't want it to be the
case I want to have all the answers and
I want to have it figured out I just
know this to be true you have to Anchor
in to something bigger than yourself to
a higher power and you have to let
go so about a year ago I got an email
from my boss my boss said hey I got us
all
tickets to go skydiving who's in and
quickly the reply alls came through I'm
out I'm out I'm out and as a matter of
spite I immediately responded I'm in
send except I'm so scared of heights I
don't like going up the Second Story
staircases when my son gets up on a
chair to change a light bulb my heart
stops I hate heights but I said I was in
and the whole flight up in this old
tankered plane with duct tape on the
inside of the plane it was duct taped
together and then came the Fateful
moment when they slam the door open I
help held on to the former special
forces guy that was Tethered to
me and before I could
answer he
jumped and in that moment We Were Free
Falling I let
go and I open my arms up enjoying the
ride Tethered to somebody who's going to
keep me
safe that's
belief
back 10 years ago when I wasn't well I
spent a year with a man who was both a
bioethics professor and a part-time monk
he said John so often sarcasm and
pessimism present as wisdom enjoy and
optimism and peace present as
foolishness as nonsense we have an O
really
culture and it's much easier to knock
their building down than it is to build
our own own and so we live and breathe
sarcasm GH pessimism you know it's all
coming down you know it's not true and
we pretend that joy and
optimism and peace and belief are
stories for children are myths of the
old age and I'll ask us just to look
around what is our sarcasm and pessimism
goddess the most anxious generation in
human
history
[Music]
I know the idea of choosing
belief is heavy there's religious trauma
that you may have gone through there are
religious systems that have burdened you
and beat you down there are scientists
and mentors and thinkers who have
laughed and scoffed at the idea of a
higher power it's just silly it's for
children but one thing I know to be
certain if you make you the center of
the world you will collapse under the
weight choose to set down sarcasm and
pessimism choose to set down intellect
solving everything choose to rest in a
higher power choose to say I
surrender I can't hold it up any longer
it's not an excuse to stop living your
life and it's not an excuse to cash out
and it's not an excuse to not go be
ambitious and try to solve some of the
world's most vexing problems we need you
I need you but I'm asking you to do it
anchored
in anchored into a higher power anchored
into God and this is belief and this is
the path to a non-anxious
[Music]
life hey what's up delone here listen
you and me and everybody else on the
planet has felt anxious or burned out or
chronically stressed at some point in my
new book building a non-anxious life
you'll learn the six daily choices that
you can make to get rid of your anxious
feelings and be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you so you
can build a more peaceful nonanxious
life get your copy today at John
[Music]
delone.org .org
slgo handed me the lyrics of the day and
as as we record this
show the Texas Rangers are up on the
Diamondbacks three games to one one game
away and if any team can have a
catastrophic failure similar to how they
ended the regular
season it's Kelly's beloved Texas
Rangers you are so bitter and it's so
fantastic oh my gosh I hope the team
they went and bought just
implodes Arizona I'm rting for you like
the
Astros listen listen
lady but I'm GNA take it like a
champ we did
lose gosh to the Rangers of all teams
man song's called I like Texas Rangers
Rangers that's the Kelly version of the
Pat Green classic well from D har to Del
Rio and out El Paso way I've been doing
fine on Houston time when the sun sets
on the copano Bay from way up where the
Red River Flows on down to the Rio Grand
I was born a little native Texan kid and
I'm proud to say go Houston Astros we'll
see you in 2024 woo Pat
Green Diamondbacks let's let do this
let's do this love you guys stay in
school don't do drugs down with the
Rangers